walk out to this video playing hon fair
2204 from from unknown there is no like
you can switch it off okay hmm laughs
I've got in my line here I think I
played that okay Knight takes is normal
then the standard way for black to place
with this g6 and later bishop fa to g7
so something like that is so quite solid
for black let's see what we get yeah but
i think i have queen h4 this is a
typical um antidote to this idea very
important the resource only available
because the night is on you too and not
only have three as it is covered in
those some iqp positions yeah cannot
hurt you have this little petty little
threat okay so just back now or to h3
maybe 2 h three actually okay I'm i have
to show by five now and this is this Oh
bow really I take en Bishop f5 should be
no Sam shouldn't it I mean there is d
for hanging
let's let's consider for a moment this
is technically interesting can take
night eggs and 92 this is this is
certainly good but is there something
better yeah okay all this it's enough
let's see nighty too I can just play 92
him can I therefore cannot take Queen
asst is detect so I just I just want to
want a piece okay I'm just to just here
to e6 he's continuing just a complete
piece down that's a I can always
continue it's not like that but it's
like there is really very very little
hope besides me blundering everything
like like no counter play on or
whatsoever I can take F 2 outs awesome
check made now it's made on age two
check check white resign yeah this was
just a very bad bad timing by whitey
this the step show on d5 I mean this
didn't lose instantly but it's a
computer says it loses instantly
interesting well I thought it would
certainly be good for me because I get
this in but the computer actually gives
black a flat-out win already yeah
probably because this is so unlucky this
is this configuration here that there
will be some material loss computer
gives this is the best line
and now look to you form yeah that is in
fact very very very bad for what you
know there's this idea doubling this the
threat rook age five if he plays a
nothing move like that will get Royce a
total killer yeah even better known as
this isn't best precise this is is just
check checkmate for the mate so this is
an additional threat after before there
were black is just doubling it has got
this active pieces just excellent really
excellent okay went here yeah this is no
very straightforward you must go here to
avoid immediate peace loss but yeah this
is this position is of course just
terrible who in how I will take here
I've porn and the the better structure
with a bad King for white cell it's a
win so he played this night takes d5 was
here one second one second it took him
two to lose the game not quite sure why
you must play this move in one second
but after that white is lost alright
thanks for watching